un incidente que ocurre alrededor de las
7 de la mañana hora local donde usted lo
informaba inicialmente dos aviones rusos
pues echaron combustible a este drone
que sobrevolaba espacio aéreo
internacional por encima del mar Negro
fue arroz fue fue le arrojaron
combustible y después Precisamente lo
estallaron ocasionando pues este
accidente que terminó Pues en en el uso
ya en el hecho de que ya no que está ya
en tierra llegó al mar Negro este dron
mq9 que aproximadamente dicen analistas
acá cuesta hasta 30 millones de dólares
al respecto James hacker general de
Estados Unidos dijo que esto eran
maniobras riesgosas muy mal calculadas y
en un en una declaración el pentágono
dice también que pues estas maniobras
mal calculadas podrían llevar a
escalamiento en en estas relaciones ya
ten entre Estados Unidos y Rusia es de
Resaltar también que pues
el gobierno estadounidense ha estado
bastante alerta de Cara a estos objetos
voladores y a estas maniobras de otros
países como china en cuanto a lo que
tiene que ver con los drones que estaban
sobrevolando el espacio aéreo
estadounidense así que pues de parte de
el gobierno de Estados Unidos están en
alerta en alerta y están muy pendientes
de la nueva información que va saliendo
de Cara a este incidente que ocurre en
nuevamente espacio internacional espacio
aéreo internacional donde aviones rusos
Pues hacen choque con este dron
estadounidense Cristóbal una duda que
surge en este contexto Qué hacen los
drones reaper en esa zona del mundo
vigilancia eran acciones de rutina
normal como describe el gobierno
estadounidense acciones de rutina de
vigilancia que estaban haciendo estos
drones estadounidenses en el mar Negro y
pues esto era esto ya se venía dando
estas acciones de estas sobrevuelos con
drones estadounidenses en el mar negros
y en espacio aéreo internacional se
venían dando ya en meses con anteriores
así que pues las acciones rusas y lo que
dice el gobierno de Estados Unidos
frente a lo que hicieron estos dos
aviones rusos pues no deja de sorprender
acá en Washington